Because of what appears to be progression of disease my ecologist is taking me off my current protocol
It is evaluating new options one of these things
That is being stopped is the Avastin. This has caused my blood pressure to go up
I'm wondering if it is possible if Avastin has been
Causing my whole system to go up. Do you think it's possible? Could it improve now that I'm off Avastin?
I don't know and I don't even know if you'd be able to find that
Google there's a website that I have listed on your member site on the homepage. That's called I think it's
Drugs.com and you can click on that link it takes you to that website and you can put it in Avastin and see what the
Possible side effects are of it. I don't know that you'll see that though
Um probably hasn't
You know typically when they have side effects of drugs and typically when drugs are tested
They're subjective side effects. They're not even doing blood work to see if if it's making objective changes
Like in the blood work like in the whole system level. So I don't I don't know that you'll see that
I have this would be the first time I've heard that so I don't it's quite possible. It's possible. So
Not to times when people ask me questions like why do I have this problem, right?
Um, I often forget
You know, I'm just out there. I haven't forget to say
Uh
Did you check the side effects of your medication and partially I'll be honest
I forget about it because I don't take medication. I never take medication and you know
Not saying that I get some people shouldn't I'm just saying I don't so I don't remember to ask for it
Just like I don't remember to ask for um, are you a smoker? You know, how much are you drinking because I don't drink or smoke
So I don't it's kind of out of my mind and
That's that's not right. I remember years ago. I had a patient
Um, who I tested for cancer and it came up
Uh, what was it aldehydes as the cause? It was just really weird. I think I hold that
It's kind of should never hurt to that. You know, I know what aldehyde is from organic chemistry
But I never heard of that be a cause. So I had to get I didn't sit out of my computer google aldehydes. What's the number one
source of aldehydes
Um in the human and it was alcohol alcohol turns to an aldehyde as it's metabolized
And I had to tell a person that it's coming up aldehyde
G are you a drinker and the galsum well, yes, I'm actually an alcoholic
I said are you recovered alcoholic you work on it should know she's still drinking
That was the cause of her cancer was the alcohol. I mean it was can't make this stuff up
Of course, I never asked her if she was an alcoholic. How bad of a doctor am I that is sex? I forget to ask people about these things
You know, so one of the things that I forget sometimes is
You know a person's symptoms
They're commonly are caused from a medication. They're on so
And you know, that's why I put that link to drugs.com
On the homepage there for you to look up for yourself
Are there subjective findings that I'm having are they possibly related to a medication that I've been taking
And you know if that's the case you want to address that or at least you know that hey now I know
Why have this instead of trying to chase it down at other way
So that should be one of the first things you look at
Unfortunately, it's one of the first things I forget